foreign
[Music]
Let's Go Minneapolis Let's Go
Minneapolis April first get your tickets
to taping my special and uh I will be in
Austin soon and a bunch of different
cities go to chrisley.com for tickets by
the way welcome to the episode the new
episode of congratulations
[Music]
I'd be really hitting that duck clip huh
dude they really got the the uh actually
the um
they figured the lips out on the on the
on the chicks didn't they the docs
finally figured them out didn't they
because chicks used to look real bad
with the duck lips and now they don't
look so bad anymore remember the fake
butts how they were bad they don't look
so bad anymore you know how you know
fake butts don't look so bad anymore
because Asian chicks got them you don't
even know remember when Asian chicks had
no ass now they got it anyway dude let's
not talk about that right up front uh
usually talk about the dicey stuff later
on in the podcast but I guess we're rip
roaring today already don't know what it
is maybe it could be my new coffee maker
that I got here in the benzo cup I don't
know why I have the Mercedes-Benz glass
that's a real real real stupid thing to
have but
he's sipping out of the Mercedes-Benz
merge dude
he's got the ice he took he made the he
made the he made the coffee for where do
you make it from oh the kitchen now his
bed how an app
oh it hurts your feelings doesn't it
dude but then what oh the cup oh but but
dude how do you get how do you make the
coffee how do you have the cup
underneath the thing already I set it up
last night he knew he was probably gonna
want it when he woke up in the morning
God he's got foresight doesn't he
oh it hurts your feeling how much
foresight he's got doesn't it so he put
the cup under the thing first of all
it's called a spin I think I don't know
what it is I got it for a Christmas
present or birthday present no Christmas
present oh my brother and my wife got it
for me oh God they went in together dude
because it's really nice it makes any
kind of coffee you want and so I got it
and this is not an ad I shouldn't even
be talking about it because they didn't
give me any aper but I'm saying I put
the cup under it at night went to bed
woke up hit the thing and it makes the
skinamarink sound too when it goes off
it goes
real loud it's scary and
um went down picked up the coffee put
the ice in it and oh
it's a pour over oh you know he drinks
coffee when he's called when he's
talking about a pour over so uh anyway
dude we got the hot merch coming out
crystalia.com go get that go get that uh
that merch the uh congratulations merch
it really do be hitting dude it really
do be hitting and the tour exclusive
merch is absolutely hyped we didn't have
it in San Antonio feel bad didn't come
through in San Antonio people in San
Antonio hit me up like why can't I have
it because of the storms baby because of
the storms we didn't even have it in
Louisiana either because of the storms
uh but the new tour report is out Rhode
Island uh it's great we brought Calvin
on stage talked about that already but
it was really sweet uh this is the
podcast episode whatever it is and uh
we're firing on all syllables dude um
you know it's uh it's been a good week
for me uh I'm oh also I added shows I
forget to tell you I added shows in
Oxnard Brea in Irvine California
to uh ramp up for my special so if
you're in Southern California a lot of
people ask about Southern California
dates there they are there they oddly
are
um
Calvin's potty trained dude you know
what the key to potty training is wait
until they're as old as you can
so they understand you dude I have so
much foresight it's crazy
I tried to potty train when he was one
and a half because I was like I bet my
son can do it early on because you hear
about some villages in like India where
it's like oh dude they're just potty
trained from jump like they come out and
they go where's the toilet
um and I don't know why that is too
because basically like
I think they kind of just poop anywhere
in India you know you're because of the
dysentery I know I'm being a little bit
I'm pushing the envelope here but it is
true dysentery is big around there and
um
so uh
wow I'm looking I'm literally looking at
oh God you know what this is hilarious I
was looking at my notes and I'm like
these notes make no sense and then I
realize that this is my these are
honestly what I'm looking at in my notes
are my therapy notes I'm like what
what is this depend on me for confidence
that's hilarious
wow depend on myself for confidence what
bit is that
so sad
um don't don't don't
try to gain acceptance from outside
sources have acceptance with myself what
what is that funny bit that I'm trying
to oh yeah it's my sad notes
oh yeah it's my notes it's my sad notes
that my csat told me to do oh
oh certified sex addiction therapist oh
that's what she said for didn't know
until recently oh
um so anyway uh what was I talking about
what was I talking about before I got
sidetracked here
we don't know
do you know why took two gabapentins
last night
had to
restless leg syndrome was was really was
it was also really be hidden
oh it's not
wow it's not even plugged in it's not
plugged in and it's all good um but yeah
you probably heard it off the I tried to
do the Jeremy renders thing
um thanks bro take these off because it
makes a really loud noise we do it
We Do It How We Do It
does it work there it is just as loud as
we want it to
um but yeah so uh potty trained my son
that's what it was and we're back
and we're back sorry for that little Gap
but that break brought to you by that
break bought to you brought to you by
Gabapentin take two forget words
brought to you by Gabapentin it helps
with anxiety
and absolutely ruins word recall
Gabapentin
long fly Ball Deep to Center and he's
outside retired this game is brought to
you by Gabapentin
um
so anyway uh that's what you do dude I
tried to potty train my son at one and a
half and I go like this you know what
never mind because he just sat there for
like a really long time
and I'm like uh really good with it too
like I'll sit with him I just love like
I love it I love it so much it just
being anywhere a a dad and um and so he
uh it now he's three and I say you know
I started prepping him I'm like you know
you're through now first of all he said
before he turned three he was like I was
like you know we gotta potty train you
two and he's trying potty trained you
soon and he said no I probably train
when I'm free and I'm like wow okay so
he turned three and I started like
witness appetite for it I was like you
know we're gonna pretty soon get rid of
the diapers dude took off his diaper and
I said tell me next time you gotta go
pee and he goes like this a few few
minutes later gotta go pee I said really
go go sit on the toilet he did it Pete
and we made such a big dude it was like
the coffin dance
with five other Nigerians just so happy
that my son peed in the plastic toilet
that wasn't even real and then three p's
later he's still doing it and then I go
upstairs for a little bit and I hear oh
my God good job bye Kristen and I said
what I ran down and she said he pooped
in there and he said Dad look and I
pooped and there were two different
colors of poop because
sometimes he's constipated and the it's
Pebbles and then under that is the
the liquid part
whatever dude if you don't have a kid
you don't know but so now he's
completely potty trained it took two
hours
that's how good it is to wait so all you
got to do is wait for the kid to
understand that this is what you because
you try took a one and a half year old
you're like yo you gotta pee you got a
poo poo in the potty and they just don't
know what you mean three now he knows
like I said my son said the word
actually the other day I'm like all
right if you say the word actually we
got a potty train you know you got no
business
uh I don't mean to talk about my kids so
much but dude it's just I I don't care
man I love it
uh and it's my life now honestly so
so that's cool so that's cool been you
know like sobriety is good
um uh it's but you know it's it's always
a struggle but it's good get lost in my
thoughts sometimes just fantasizing you
know going a little bit oh you know what
I gotta depend on me for confidence
that's what it is too that's what it is
too because also when I was in rehab I
wasn't doing any any sort of I didn't
have any sort of distraction like that
was that was a real hard thing to do no
distraction zero distraction no phone
dude zero distraction you know what the
distraction was thoughts you ever have
to distract your thoughts with thoughts
I did for over 30 days and I realized I
was going to bed and I was I was just
like I would just like think of things
that like you know I had no business
thinking of just like you know
fantasizing or whatever and I'd be like
dude why am I doing this I'm doing this
because I'm uncomfortable here in this
basically
you know a halfway house with barrels
and so um you know I had roommates and I
was sleeping like a twin bed and I felt
uncomfortable baby yes and so what I did
was I would distract myself and thought
to then I was like why am I doing this
dude I'm doing this because I don't want
to feel the fear he has dude and so what
I did was I thought about other things
and then I caught myself and I was like
dude let's just feel the feelings
nerd it's all good my babies it's what's
real is what's funny that's what they
say
like And subscribe I don't know what
else you want dude but let's grow this
cult man because dude and I'm not
showing you you can look at my Instagram
and I don't wanna but dude I'm yet I
mean dude he's yet it up now for real
he's yet it up for real
he's got an actual house on him what the
only other guy's got a house on his arm
is Joel Kinnaman
dude what
he's like the comedic Joe kinnamon
what
years ago I saw Joe kitten had a house
in his arm and I commented he's got a oh
you got a whole house on your arm and he
wrote yeah I got a house tattoo and I go
okay forgot about it
for years
and then guy got a house on my arm but
it's not on the house is it it's a log
cabin because we're in the tall grass
and we share ideas and now we got a
blueprint for it don't we babies we got
a blueprint it's right there
Bury Me With The Log Cabin
you understand
Bury Me With The Log Cabin you can't not
unless of course I die by getting my
arms sewn off
saw it off rather
um so yeah bury me with the log cabin
but so anyway dude uh my son's potty
trained I got a tattoo of a house on me
and my wife is eight months pregnant
other than that that's what's going on
those are the greatest things
um
yeah dude and oh and also Tinkerbell's
black
and I'm for it
I don't care I like it you know me right
you know me
I want I don't want just
I don't want
only cartoons to be switched up to black
people I I want every role to be only
black people so I don't even have to
think about ever being in a movie ever
again or or a TV show I want them to
make a legitimate TV series about Abe
Lincoln and have Taye Diggs play Abe
Lincoln
and then it's like well but it doesn't
make sense because he was the one who
abolished it yeah okay I don't care dude
I want everybody in the thing to be
I want 12 Years a Slave I want
Chadwell chat way to play the guy and
then I want all the other people that
also I wanted the the James uh
who's the guy in Boston Legal James
Spader I want that part to be black
is he in it no he's in a blinking I
messed up now I'm racist against white
guys but um
yeah dude
I I just I want it all because here's
the thing they made Tinkerbell black and
now you cannot and I I said I wouldn't
say that w-o-k-e world word anymore on
this podcast for this episode only
because I say it so much but you just
they eat their own you can't dude they
tried to do that and now the wokee
people are like you know what
yeah oh you're making the cartoon why
can't we get our own so it's like dude
and half of them are white people saying
so it's like you can't win so just keep
it how it is and that or switch the
whole thing the whole thing
there should not be white people doing
anything anymore
anything dude I want all the jobs to be
forget it
I'm in dude
make Tinkerbell make Peter Pan make them
all people of color that's what I want
dude and I won't be happy until then I
won't rest until honestly I won't rest
until Peter Pan is being played by Mindy
uh
whatever that woman is called what's her
name Kaling is that the woman from the
mini Kaling show
the what show
oh Scooby-Doo Velma right is she Velma
oh there you go Velma was right right
and now she's good dude he made it even
though he fell into it
and what I care my son's potty trained
dude
I'm done
I'm having another one we're having baby
we're having another baby so and you
know that but uh yeah
so Tinkerbell's black and I'm all for it
um you know what they should do honestly
just make the two of the same movies one
with white one with black and then one
with Asian and then one with whatever
that's how that that's actually how it
used to be huh they just be America was
just the ones where they just make the
white movies and then I they would
probably make other movies in other
places that were other people with other
colors were
but whatever dude I don't know man
anymore it's okay it's it's gonna be
fine
um it's good you know why it's gonna be
fine too is because Tom Brady's Tom
Brady has announced he wants to do stand
up
why do why I look if you're the greatest
football player of all time or if you're
a football player after that only either
be an announcer or open up some sort of
Warehouse that sells suits right that's
it
that's it or have a restaurant maybe
even though that's kind of annoying but
use your name for something dude stand
up comedy why do people think and I
don't I don't I'm not one of those guys
that thinks that oh great Tom Brady is
doing stand-up this is the death of
stand-up comedy dude I don't care about
that the whole hip-hop is dead thing is
stupid right hip hop is real it's just
not what's getting the clicks which is
fine
I mean there's still nods out there
doing that thing but it's like
you know Papoose isn't really around
anymore and he was true hip-hop I got a
fitted hat on my head a fitted hat on my
head
um
what was that
I got my hater blockers on block him out
I got my haters he was real hip-hop dude
Papoose
what happened to him man oh I loved that
song anyway
um
so but yeah I'm real hip-hop I believe
hip-hop but so uh Tom Brady is has
announced he wants to do stand-up uh
he's not doing sports anymore he wants
to focus on his stand-up career which is
hilarious that'd be like like think
about how silly that sounds if I was
just all of a sudden like dude I really
want to focus on my architect career I
don't have one
Tom Brady throws footballs and he like
you don't have to be like yeah I really
want to focus I want to focus on my chef
career honestly oh I don't cook dude
he did it zero times my career
I don't know why people get so
successful in their thing and they want
to do something else dude before that
happens to me bury me
because like
you figured out what you do you're the
goat there you go even God up in heaven
is like
Golden Arm
this is so annoying even God is like God
damn it
cambre are you serious Tom oh God I
would kill him but then everyone would
kill him early but then there would be
like a whole thing about it and be so
annoying I'd have to keep watching
specials about it be all over the news I
don't I'm so pissed off
devil can you get your claws in them
I've been working on it
but it just seems so goddamn perfect
so nobody's doing stand-up comedy and
he's talking to like Netflix about doing
what I do
so anyway you ever been on the 25-yard
line and
oh
yeah
Giselle just at home just getting
pipelate on or you start going out the
other night she was just dancing so hard
man giselle's really a hot ticket she is
right she was out having fun in like
some boxy just dancing around man when
your wife is so hot here's the thing Tom
Brady is the goat when your wife is so
hot and then she and you're both famous
and then she you guys break up and then
you gotta see viral videos of her doing
mom dancing to the Mambo Number Five
with like some skater boys oh my god
dude
no wonder who wants to do stand-up
comedy these guys just everyone thinks
they're Joe Rogan they think they could
do anything there's two guys who can do
anything Joe Rogan and Bo Jackson and
where'd Beau end up right
remember those pictures of him with the
football thing on and he's just
um I mean even Deion Sanders couldn't
really do it all he tried he's good he's
good at announcing but
um
anyway dude Tom Brady is going to do
stand up can't wait for it can't wait
for it even though I think a black guy
should have that job
um
I just think it's absolutely phenomenal
I I dude my son was uh I would he's been
like regressing on the sleep schedule a
little bit like finally like he's been
sleeping so great and now he uh
I don't know if he gets he's getting
scared or it's the separation anxiety
but like he goes we put him to bed and
he's been saying he's been like will you
lay with me for a bit and my my wife who
will do that I say like yo babe I think
that we gotta like not do that because
if we we gotta curb it quick because if
we get into a habit of doing it then
it's gonna be even harder to curb and
she's like okay you're right okay so I
said I'll tell you what I'll do the I'll
do the uh
you partied oh did you go with number
one number two
you did PP
amazing well don't come in don't come in
because he's got his underwear on right
do you want PP yes dude
yeah
yes
oh he just went like that as he was
leaving love you
um
wow that's amazing dude he went pee pee
um but uh
oh that's so cute so uh
wow that's awesome so he um
so he's been like I don't know if it's
so so I said so I said to my wife about
the sleeping thing
um
about the sleeping thing uh I was like
uh I was like will man that totally
messed me up that's so awesome that's so
awesome he did it without me
um that he that I was like I'll take
care of this him going to sleep I'll do
it right because I don't have shows in
in town right now because I'm just doing
the road
and like I just love I just want to be
at home
so I'm like I'm here at night because
also he's got late late hours
because he's got he's on comic time so
I'm like why don't I do it so I've been
like putting in the bed and he would be
like will you left me for a bit and I'll
say buddy so I'm not gonna do that
because
um
I don't want to uh
you need to go to bed because I think
you can do it you're a big boy right can
you at least try and they'll say okay
and then he'll say can you leave the
door open for a bit and so I
oh can you leave the door a little bit
open that's what he says so I leave the
door open now and so what happens is
I'll hear like Pitter patters and he'll
be running into my room it's so so
because one time I walked out of his
room I started walking downstairs and I
heard and he was running to my room and
I was like buddy I'm over here and he
looked at me and he was like oh
and it was just really really because I
used to be so scared when I was a kid
still so
um still think about Skinnamarink so um
less than three weeks ago can't go to
bed can't go to bed with the baby
monitor on um because it makes the same
noise
so anyway
um I I brought him uh I I put him down
and then I said I'll leave the door a
little bit open
stay here if you need to if it's
necessary all you got to do is call for
me I'll come right in so I walk out of
the door and I remember one time when I
was a kid and my dad said buddy you got
to go to school and I didn't want to I
was scared of everything I'm way more
scared than Calvin was about everything
I was so scared I was scared about I
didn't sleep through the night until I
was 13.
whoops admitted it would call my parents
in a room every night until I was 13.
whoops admitted it
one time tried to sleep over Chris
Siegel's house
couldn't do it had to go to the bathroom
wouldn't go to the bathroom because I
was too scared woke up in the middle of
night with a log of [__] halfway coming
out of my ass whoops admitted it
okay so and that's why they call it
dirty jerseys so
so I I was um
and so I stand outside of the door and I
wait for him to say Dad and I come in
and say hey buddy and he says what you
doing
and I was like I'm just watching TV and
he says that's interesting and I'm like
okay buddy well I'm gonna go out if you
need me just call me he says okay I walk
out two minutes later dad
I pretend like I'm not standing right
there because I don't want him to think
I'm right there so then I wait a little
bit and then I walk in and say hey buddy
he said what you doing I said oh I'm
just going downstairs to watch TV he
says okay
anyway
uh the other day
I finally was like because I don't want
to be like hey are are you scared
because then I don't want to introduce
that thought into his mind in case he's
not scared he's just like doesn't want
to go to sleep and he's crying because
he doesn't want to go to sleep so
finally I was like buddy so what is the
deal why do you not want to go to bed uh
lately what's going on and he was like
oh I don't know you leave the door a
little bit open I said is it is it maybe
that you're like scared of something and
he and he says yes I said are you scared
and he said yes I said of what and he
said spider's in my room and I said oh
buddy well you don't have to worry about
spiders spiders first of all there's no
spiders in your room second of all
spiders are our friends they eat other
insects that are like you know Annoying
and stuff and he said really I said yeah
so you're scared of spiders and he said
yeah and I said oh you don't have to be
and he said can we get one tomorrow
I said you want to get a pet spider he
said yes so now here's the deal I'm
terrified of spiders
okay I gotta get a [__] spider now
because my son wants a Peppa he won't
stop talking about it can we get a pet
spider so now oh he turned it on its ass
no it's me who's scared
now I'm scared of spiders whoops I
admitted it
but I am dude and I kept that close to
the chest in case like I don't want fans
coming up to me being like here look
here look right here look at the spider
look the way they hold it here look here
he is oh there he is there he is in
their mouth
so now I gotta get a hairy you know what
I mean
we're not getting a spider but he wants
a spider and I [__] up by asking him
if he was scared so now I'm confronted
with my scariness
and that ain't and that's what it's like
being a father dude
and now I gotta I gotta I sometimes I
sit with him in his his and guess what
no I can turn my baby monitor off in my
room but guess what I can't do turn the
sound machine off in his room
because so now I got the
that's the same noise the skinny ring
I'm actually scared in the bed with
Calvin and I'm scared because I'm there
and he's scared because he's there and
we're both sitting there scared of [__]
and I'm not lying to you either I get
freaked out
and Mom's eight months pregnant in the
bed just like this
just on this uh sleeping with like
listening to some murder podcast
foreign
app this is the com app by the way this
is the other day
here hold on
this is the other day I laughed so hard
because
let me send it to you I got it right
here I laughed so hard because she's
listening to the com to the com app
where's the lifeline uh
where's the light where's the LA dude
when is the last time we texted on
Lifeline oh I'm pissed oh I'm pissed
there it is dude got it so here's the
deal this is what
this is what we played
just listen to this this is so awesome
hey there my name is chips I Karaoke
[__] shibs
also hey there
my name's chibs or karakay dude his
family was at uh a syllabus a sale for
syllables
I will take the k
uh uh you know what I'll take two k's a
rare
oh you gotta know there and then what do
you have left over chibs oh I'll use
that for the first one so chips okay
okay we'll make it chips or carrot cake
they came back with a bunch of syllables
look what I got family Rey o k two k's
and then our chibs and they go Dad oh
we're gonna make with that
I don't know these were the sale and we
don't have much money
what can we make
and then and then the phone and then
phone rang and they're like what do we
say what
hello
and they were like you did it
the chips a carry K hello chips hello oh
Curry K residents
chibs dude
chabs is his name that's great oh do you
know how much I'm gonna name my second
child chibs chibs Dalia
what kind of what's the origin for that
it sounds like really really
distinguished and we were laughing about
it the last night and then Kristen's
like how did he he still makes it sound
he's the guy's sexy
hey there
my name is chebso karikay
my name is [__]
my name is [__] splooge a lot
hey there my name is shed head
splurgella splooge dude
wow man
how do you
hey there
chibs what you know dude it would be so
annoying to have a name where people
would go what afterwards what dude what
my wife the other day said what do you
think of the name because you know we
don't know what we're gonna name the
second kid yeah we have a few names that
are
kind of you know
contenders but she says uh what do you
think of the name and when she does it
I'm like this better be good because for
some reason guy names are terrible
they're all terrible
names for like girls they're they're
awesome I got we got a list of them
we're not having girls
so
she's like what about the name Ledger
and I was like no I don't like names
that are things
you know what I'm saying
it's like naming your son camera
like just
Tim is fine
the only thing worse than that is a name
where you'd have to be like it's what
the whole night the whole life night you
know
so anyway
hey there my name is chibs okay
dude just so
hey there
my name's jib so karaoke
tonight we're gonna do something called
progress
hey there my name is chibs out karikay
my family bought these syllables long
ago
they had a sale on o k
Chivas
re
and that's it
we jumbled them up and now I'm chibzone
Kerry gay
my son
's KK is
oh
chips KK wow when I woke up this morning
I never thought I'd say that ribs touch
it KK uh anyway dude that's the dumbest
thing we've ever done in this podcast
it's all good it was still uh
dude I was watching it's still not as
dumb as the hype show on HBO Max I love
HBO Max HBO Max the hottest [__] HBO Max
is the hottest [__] I mean every
character is either
you know gay or trans and that's fine
but do it when I'm all for it like HBO
Max is the [__] and
um they want so there's one show called
hype on it and they got uh it has
um what's his name
offset or whatever
hey there my name is offset
I bought set and off at the syllable
store
it was either set off offset set off
made too much sense
um
by the way if you want to impress black
people just mention the movie Set It Off
and they'll be like oh [__] how you know
Set It Off
how you know that one
oh oh I said set it off in front of two
black people the other day and they go
are you for real
who the hell are you Jim so carry K so
um
what was I saying about the oh yeah I
was watching this thing and it's
basically offset is on it and then two
designers and uh and and one is from who
made Union Los Angeles uh the the com
the brand and then the other one who is
a stylist for like
Kylie Jenner and chips okay I don't know
and so it's a competition show where
these people just kind of have a
um
compete to who's the best designer with
fashion and you know what dude straight
up I'm I'm actually done talking about
it
I'm I don't I'm not doing it dude I
don't want to we make up our minds as we
go I don't want to talk about it anymore
dude and that's fine okay but it's a
movie on HBO a show on HBO Max I started
watching it on the airplane and it was
it was dude I don't want to talk about
it and it was oh it was good there were
moments and [__] and like
the some of the outfits were ridiculous
and also I get it but also I kind of
want to dress like offset dude man I
want to dress like I said that dude is
handsome I didn't know he's handsome bro
I just think of them as that goofy rap
group
but like God man
officer really do be killing it man
and he knows his fashion [__] but I'm
not talking about it
um
hi there
my name is Chip zalkarekai
I opened the bar moose mcgillicuddies
um
that was a bar in um that was a bar in
Pasadena California and I would go
sometimes and I would go and we would
hang out and one time there was the I
mean I must have been 23 and there was
the hottest chick there and she was
dancing and we were hanging out dancing
I guess dancing at a bar I I think I was
which it doesn't even sound right for me
but I was 23 was a lifetime ago and
she was like I want to hang out with you
and I was like what
like I wasn't famous then I was like
what she was like I want to hang out
with you I want to go home with you and
I was like
to wear my parents house like I I I
didn't live with my parents anymore but
I lived in Burbank and I was out of the
driveway I was like you do and she was
like yeah and I was like
and I actually was like I don't think I
can and I didn't and why
thank you
dude
why didn't I
hmm 34 year old me would have smashed it
into Oblivion
23 year old me was a little [__]
was I scared
well she made of spiders
dude so I didn't do it
Shoulda didn't all good but that man I'm
talking about the two times and then one
time I was in Vancouver I was 19.
I was at a bar and man this
this woman came up to me older than me
and she was like
what's up and I mean I'm talking about
dude
her figure was like
hourglass no
it was like a whole three hours
right and I do and and I and I was like
what's up and she was like take me back
to your hotel room and I was like and I
was shooting a movie and I was like
okay
and she's like let's go and I was like
yeah let's go and then I left and didn't
do it dude she was not a 10. she was a
whole 11 and I just bitched out and I'm
just like
I regret those two yeah
[Music]
but we didn't do it why dude what was
her name I don't remember but then I saw
her later on in Hollywood she was like
sup and I was like oh what's up I'm
grown now and we never did any yes dude
all good we can regret things but not
that but it's you know
man if I was chims I'll carry Kai he I
would have cleaned up dude
imagine how much tail you get your name
is chibs
I remember I remember I would think like
look obviously I got a lot of you know
my I did fine in my day but
uh when I was I would think man you know
the only way I would get laid more would
be if my name I I actually thought this
was true
I thought
my brain is I thought the only time the
only time I would get laid more the only
thing that would help me is if my name
was
if my name was Oliver
the thing I thought
and I was like if my name was Oliver
dude
just
straight up just
me my sex life but
just superimposed just didn't don't
stink to just forget it dude for real
like my just
superimposed with the graphs going up
and me just
no not that one just absolutely just if
my name is Oliver and then I met a guy
named Spencer once and I was like dude
if my name was Spencer dude or Oliver
dude are you
are you I wouldn't even need legs
because I'd be laying down forever it
would just be
oh my gosh I'd be a ride
it would be insane forget it
I could just be you know what my whole
money my name was Spencer or Oliver my
name could have just been horizontal
because dude that's all I'd be
horizontal Delia just
no legs Dalia just he don't need him
though why
just straight up man
files done
love it my favorite on the soundboard
dude
um
yeah man
it we're at the point where you know
what if you
I have such I'm so dumb dude there was a
guy with a cleft lip in my
high school that was like the older dude
that was like the cool dude and he had a
cleft lip and he got it the surgery and
he looked real nice with it with the
scar and I was like that's the guy bro
that's the guy that's gonna clean up he
may not clean up now in high school I
guarantee this dude this dude is gonna
need to bring towels everywhere wherever
this guy goes because also he plays
soccer that's a dark horse spot that's a
dark horse sport where you get the most
tail soccer because it's baseball yeah
basketball yeah we get it football the
main ones but soccer dude the chicks go
oh really I don't really know it I don't
know
and then you've got a cleft lip dude
I guarantee that dude is dead now
because of too much
[Music]
anyway man it's just like dude these are
the things these are the things I would
busy myself thinking about this uh
Chris Rock special I did not see it but
I saw the um
thing about Will Smith dude he went hard
in the paint it was at the last five
minutes of this special is what I heard
I don't know but I just saw a clip
online that's first of all brilliant to
put it the last five minutes
because he's like everyone's like
waiting for it and then he did and he
was calling Will Smith a [__] in it I
was like wow that's hard that's hard as
[__] and of course it was shitty that
Will Smith did that and you know
if you're gonna smash somebody in the in
the uh
if you're gonna smack somebody in the
face then and do or do a one of the best
comedians in the world
you know he's obviously going to talk
about and make fun of you so
Will Smith his weather in a few uh
probably weather in the storm right now
but um
yeah
uh yeah he he went hard you guys should
watch at least that part I didn't see
the rest of it so I don't know uh Chris
Rock's one of my favorites though and uh
he was uh
I mean he was like
talking about how uh Will Smith wild is
the worst recap of all time but I'm just
like thinking about it like you just
call him a [__] and [__] and like it
was so funny
uh
and that's it dude and I don't want to
talk about it anymore and I do what I
want so but yeah I know people probably
what do you think about the Chris Rock
thing so that's what I think about it it
was funny he's hilarious and um
it's tough for uh what do you call it
well Will Smith no probably because of
that I watched some of the Alex Murdoch
uh thing he was found guilty Alex
Murdoch is it Murdoch
they say on the documentary say Murdoch
and then they also say Alec
it's so it's like his name is Alex
murdaugh
and they say Murdoch in the documentary
they add a k and then drop the X for
Alec so it's like dude but it's a Lex no
wonder this guy who [__] wound up
killing his family
guys gotta [__] you know murder
murder but Alex Murdoch but Alec Murdoch
huh
that's enough to start stabbing honestly
dude obviously uh
I don't know if he got found guilty I
guess he did it so but dude the [__]
I was watching document with my my wife
and I don't I don't like to watch those
things man they're just so like they're
all the same like how many murder
documentaries are gonna watch you know
like they're every it's like every every
every [__] day and a half Netflix is
like
the [__] Sam [__] Jones murders
and you're like who's this guy I think
they're just making up people at this
point it's like just hey you're like
watching the thing you're like is this a
real guy or did AI do this one and it
shows up a picture of him he's got seven
fingers you're like this is AI
hey why can't AI catch up on the finger
game
this is what everybody's hands look like
in AI this is one hand
you follow a AI
nah nine fingers on like an old lady get
with it dude and like a tit on the side
of her face what's wrong with aiaa I get
it together dude
um
so
they're making them up dude
foreign
kept doing it with the uh Murdoch
whatever the [__] his name is and I kept
saying like God he is handsome to her
and he is so like the ugliest guy in the
world you know like if you were to like
scientifically figure out the ugliest
person he would be in top ten
right it'd be him Kenneth Branagh and
anyone else who's pasty with red hair
you know like the ugliest guys
kind of red hair
yeah I'm talking about dude
like kinda red hair and if you
do that to their anywhere on their body
it immediately turns pink
those are the ugliest guys
and that guy just and then he made two
more people like that
what man if you're like a kind of Ginger
and you marry a kind of Ginger don't
procreate dude
they're gonna be in the top ten
so then the case the kid was just like
nutso dude and just ran I mean he didn't
even run people over he [__] used a
boat to kill people which is crazy dude
that's so rich
that's so rich to kill someone on your
boat
wow
that sucks man that whole thing sucks
dude my heart goes out to the the little
the little uh was it a was he in high
school or was she in college or whatever
it was man my heart goes out to her
that's rough man I don't know how these
families deal with that [__] I don't
know how they deal with it I don't know
how they deal with it man like I cannot
I God bless man these people who live
through those things like the families
who live through those things
they are a special type of person they
are a strong person I guess you just
have to keep moving forward but oh my
god dude
a lot of people die in Tom Sizemore
we knew that guy was gonna die though
right like we knew he wasn't going to
get to 70. he was 61. he was [__]
great
he was a great actor in um he was in
Saving Private Ryan he was like such a
good actor and then he would do movies
where he was like I don't care what the
script is
what are they pay me uh you know what I
don't even care let me just do it
they're paying me 40 grand for for three
months work in New Zealand and it's
about a what a killer pumpkin I don't
give a [__] man I'll go
do I have to wear a shirt
you know
and then like there was a thing like in
2000 and it did I don't know I actually
shouldn't talk about that because he's
the Tom Sizemore and he just died but
Tom Sizemore is um
he was he was great he was a great actor
um R.I.P Tom Sizemore
what's this here
this is something one fire sent me
who's this guy Jerry Boys on um
on uh
tick tock
come on won't go great
Ivan did it
oh Chrome it is Chrome
oh here we go
it won't play for some reason that's
great yes
dude my drunk girls thing went [__]
super viral again on Tick Tock your boy
Can't Stop on Tick Tock dude not the
only one getting steak tonight buddy
what's up I was saying watch the tough
guy
I'm trying to get some steak but that's
all that's something what does that have
to do with me over here looking for
steak no it's you're in the way pets
good that's all you got a [__]
problem dude let's [__] hand
s 100 series bro
who comes up to somebody in the Giant
when they're getting steak and tries to
cause Broadway no offense I'm not
causing a problem buddy you're in the
way oh I'm in the way yeah I'm sorry my
shoulders are bigger than your [__]
whole body smash them
friend bro
I don't know ask this guy with that no
what would you do yeah walk off
pipsqueak
I don't know is your buddy like one song
tonight I don't know him
he comes up to me and tells me I'm in
the way of the snake and they called me
pit squeak dude are you kidding me how
was she even win
it doesn't matter buddy okay I'm sure
you're a champion yeah how'd you know
buddy I'm a UFC champion
wow dude oh I gotta watch that again
that's [__] actually hilarious
hey man you're in the way the steak bro
that's a tough guy not the only one
getting lost tough guy he's not the only
one getting steak tonight buddy what's
up I was saying watch the tough guy
no I'm being serious though I'm trying
to get some steak but that's all I
it's actually so confusing the way he's
doing it and this guy has no idea what's
happening that's so funny dude
yo watch out tough guy you're not the
only one getting steak tonight no I'm
being dead serious man I'm just trying
to get some steak tonight
we gotta play more does are there more
of these
there's so many oh let's look at more
bro this guy Jerry boys let's look at
another one here
oh the look on this guy's face already
here we go why does it take a long time
to do it
in the past
I'm pissed
why is it taking so long oh this is
great how long it's taking
why is it taking so long
yeah I'm on the right Network dude it's
my Wi-Fi dude I live here
he says okay on the right Network
who says are you on the right Network
when it's my house dude
I have two networks that's true
they're both good right
one of them which one's bad the one say
it quiet so they don't hear it so that
no one contacts into my [__]
oh I'm on the bad one how's it going
Young Buck hey what's up not much man I
remember when I was your age
no seriously by the time are you my age
yeah man yeah good years those were
I'm uh I'm 56 right now
huh
oh appreciate the compliment sir you
know I didn't huh you got 20. no I'm 56.
no you're not
how could you say so buddy come on
because you're gonna look 20 anyway how
you can be 56. I appreciate that man I
get that a lot man yeah yeah you know
you eat healthy
you smoke dope man yeah I'll do it for
you yeah thank you man
oh yeah man enjoy your day Young Buck
you too thank you
wow dude I gotta follow this guy
okay I'm on the bad Wi-Fi I'm not
getting a good Wi-Fi
uh I'm on a good one
the ultimate
there's another ultimate one
oh dude he's got he's hiding wifis
because hiding Wi-Fi is in my own house
you're gonna give me another one another
good one from the
foreign
look at these guys dude these are
hilarious let me look at the ones I got
that
the this one's got a lot of things all
right let me do this one
here we go
oh this Wi-Fi sucks too
it's not doing it I gotta follow this
Jerry Boys on Tick Tock holy [__] dude
that's funny
I'm not I gotta get on it I gotta it's
not doing it
it's not doing it dude what what's wrong
with this wi-fi
okay because I'm pissed
my computer I gotta get a new computer
hasn't been updated for like six years
here we go oh watch the tough guy
very good watch the pipsqueak
wow
oh watch a tough guy just so
watch the pipsqueak
I mean so dick just so dick dude to be
doing that
oh here this has 1.3 million this will
be good
wow the guy's got the tree tattoos on
his arm you know that guy that that's so
funny so this one's Jerry boys it's
called I don't know it says pip squeak
on the thing come on I'm in PIP squeak
who calls someone pip squeak that's so
funny yo watch your pipsqueak
hahaha
here we go waiting for it to play for
some reason it's great
it's great because we're waiting for it
to play that's great dude thanks for
sitting with me guys like And subscribe
at this point here we go I said watch
huh you heard me
yep all right yeah
I mean so dick wow that's really how is
the guy doing it so funny
oh my God you're stuck in an elevator
with this guy
okay here we go
ladies first
ladies first lady oh
oh no I'm saying you you can go ladies
first yeah
[Music]
Oh I thought I was gonna say like thanks
lady at the end that would have been
amazing all right let me go here's he
says another one
uh one fire sent me another good one
here we go
excuse me pipsqueak
it's all to me yeah
we'll call him oh [__] all right it's
not a problem right
nah you walk around though around yeah
why is that
I disrespectful all right can I get
around this week
all right can we restart
no
you're in the way bro don't call me no
more names all right lip squeak
I'm just trying to get by right
awesome but you're in the way sucker
goodbye
oh come on go man can we can we start
can we restart no
dude that one's good holy [__] excuse me
pipsqueak
talk to me yeah don't call me pipsqueak
all right it's not a problem right
around yeah
yeah God I want to see what this guy
looks like
are you guys gonna get laid out he's
gonna get laid out
that guy was huge bro
here we go I mean this one says 50 Cent
son
out the way pets week I said out the way
pipsqueak yeah that's so disrespectful
to not even say the whole sentence I'm
saying you're a pit squeaker in my way
say excuse me all right bro next time
I'll say excuse me pipsically grab say
that now all right I don't have to move
you see me doing something right what
are you doing are you shopping
keep your window shopping
oh my god dude
out the way pipsqueak out the way
pipsqueak out the way pipsqueak out the
way yeah
I don't get it I'm saying you're a pit
squeaker in my way say excuse me all
right bro next time I'll say excuse me
pick squeak all right say that now I
don't have to move you see me doing
something right what are you doing are
you shopping
you know what are you doing you shopping
you're window shopping
good you it's so funny because you can
hear that the guy's nerve is doing it
wow what that could get laid out he kind
of deserves to too that's crazy
those are the best three God that first
one was [__] hilarious
I'll watch it again
watch tough guy not the only one getting
steak tonight buddy what's up I was
saying watch a tough guy
not being serious I'm trying to get some
steak but that's all
that's all you got a [__] problem
dude let's [__] handle this series
bro
who comes up to somebody in the Giant
when they're getting steak and tries to
cause Broadway and no offense I'm not
causing a problem
oh I'm in the way yeah well I'm sorry my
shoulders are bigger than your [__]
whole body dude okay buddy the illest
illest slam
yeah walk off biblically
I don't know
he comes up to me
dude are you kidding me how was she even
weigh the weight doesn't matter buddy
okay
championship
fight yeah how'd you know buddy I'm a
UFC champion
oh my God
I mean
does your friend want something tonight
also
I want to talk about this dude there's a
tick tock this guy so hold on
I want to watch some of this guys tick
tocks
you know why dogs are better than cats
because a cat will try to bite your hand
off if you accidentally touch it in the
exact wrong spot but you could smack a
dog in the nose and they're like do you
want to play Frisbee
so people are
saying
that this guy who
I think I've met him before
I guess he's a successful stand-up
comedian
people are saying that he
he's faking the clips like
he doesn't have clips of audience
members
is this right no
it can't be that who does that
I hope he's doing that honestly to game
the system for real because these clips
are so stupid not his but it's so stupid
if you ever listen to a stranger's
conversation for so long that you get
super into it
for 25 minutes I was listening to a girl
in a coffee shop cry about her boyfriend
until I was like excuse me you don't
know me but you need to leave him
I can't believe he would treat you like
that
you are so much better than this
he doesn't deserve you
do you ever listen to a stranger's
conversation it actually does have a
weird doesn't it sound
maybe his audiences are just [__]
killer bro
honestly if he's doing this more power
to him because it's so stupid these
clips on they'll [__] post anything
now people these crowd work clips
like I discern the [__] whether or not I
post it it's good or not I mean there's
so many crowd work Clips I'm like nah
this one's not that good I'm not gonna
post it people are just like uh hey what
do you do for a living on Tick Tock and
then the audience might be like oh dude
I'm a chef and someone's like oh what do
you make dude
[__]
and then they'll post and be like yo I'm
coming in [__] on the thing to be
like Buffalo New York I'm coming like I
don't understand this whole Tick Tock
thing but I I post only the good ones on
my Tick Tock and yeah my tick tock goes
dummy viral and yeah you know when I
post the shits it goes nutso but you
know it's just like
is this guy is this my buddy sent me
this and he's like people think it's a
fake do you ever listen to a stranger's
conversation first I don't care bro he
gained the system good for him if he
makes a career off this I'll tell you
what I'm buying tickets to his next show
and I'm being serious I support this
kind of behavior
I got so lonely during quarantine that I
went on a website for adult videos
and in the search box where you type in
your fetish
I wrote
genuine enthusiasm
wow
is it real what do you guys think leave
it in the comments
um you know what I'm gonna bleep his
name out in the podcast because I don't
want people to like
get mad at them and stuff because I
actually
look at the comments All believe it
maybe it's real
this is funny
oh I hope he gets a career for real
maybe he probably already has one but
this is
this is very interesting because it
sounds fake
I am not the most confident person in
the entire world I think this is real
person has got to be
um the guy who is in charge of web
design at Craigslist
this is real
this is real that dude has never second
guessed himself
in his entire life
[Laughter]
this is real you can tell they came to
this guy like hey we are building a
brand new website it's going to connect
entire cities we've been trying to
figure out who we want to design it
and we've chosen you you'll have a team
of people at your disposal whatever you
dream up we can make and the guy was
like
this is a funny bit
website huh
I got it
I want
all
texts
all the same
size and color
I'm done
this is a funny bit dude that's real
that's a funny bit dude if it's fake why
why he can actually do it he can
actually do real stand-up that's funny
it's that's weird that makes me think
the other ones are fake
interesting
that's a funny bit guys funny
okay hold on I'm going to another one
I'm like deep in this now boy would I
look at that I'm glad I'm honestly I'm
glad I'm watching this on a podcast
because I was watching this in real life
I would spend hours doing this yes here
we go here's another one you ever try to
order from a restaurant but their
website is so frustrating that you just
give up an order from somewhere else
I thought I wanted Sesame beef but your
shopping cart system is such garbage
that suddenly I have a craving for pizza
it just tastes so easy to order is that
is that HTML5
interesting
I wonder well I believed his name out
okay
Ivan I believed his name out just so you
don't need to know who he is but because
I don't I don't know if that is fake or
not I don't want to start something but
that uh that was interesting but that
that bit was funny the one that's
definitely live is funny so he can do it
so why would he do the fake one maybe it
is real I don't know wow
um yeah so okay well look that's that's
good
um
that's good on you guys thank you very
much uh I appreciate you guys uh I'm
gonna be shooting uh my special go to
chrissy.com to get tickets uh and go to
chrissy.com I'll be in uh you know um
Austin Minneapolis
um uh this will come out when when does
this come out I'll be in oh I'll be in
Midland I'll be in Kansas no this will
come out tonight Kansas City uh and
Tulsa
which is a weird Market but I'll be in
Tulsa and uh I got other ones coming up
Columbus Ohio and uh other ones in Ohio
and also Utah and Milwaukee all right
that's it for the episode on YouTube if
you want to get the raw uncut the
unedited unedited episode go to uh Chris
uh patreon.com
crystallia that's on my patreon and
there are about 24 episodes that are
private for only the patreon people
you'll get that for just six bucks uh
and every month we come out with a new
episode that is only on patreon and uh
there's other stuff too other stuff too
I was talking to this the Discord on
patreon the other day we chat have a
good time so go on over to patreon.com
crystalia and uh check us out thanks
foreign
[Music]